So, now let's see which ones of these
benefits can actually be expected. Definitely, the first one.
The modular coding style typical of object-oriented approaches can,
and normally does, increase reuse. Similarly, because of the
characteristics of typical object-oriented systems, these systems are normally
easier to change. Because they're more modular, they're more
cohesive, they're more decoupled. And therefore, all of this
contributes to increase the maintainability of the resulting systems.
So we're going to mark this benefit as well.
There's really nothing about object-oriented systems. That make them
run faster and, therefore, this is not a benefit
that we can expect from the use of an
object-oriented approach. Conversely, the last one is an expected
benefit because normally, the fact of designing real-world entities,
which is one of the characteristics of the object
oriented approaches, does increase understandability. It's easier to understand
the system because we can relate. To the system because we can recognize in
the systems, real world entities that we are used to see and that we understand.